hello and welcome to this week in
Android development for jun 17 2013 my
name is reto Meier if it feels like it's
been more than a week since the last
week in Android development you can
blame these three troublemakers who flew
in from the UK for google i/o between
keeping them out of trouble and
preparing over 30 technical sessions for
the conference our team has had its
hands full we've shipped them safely
back to London and also made the iOS
session videos available for you to
watch in the comfort of your own home
one of the biggest announcement said I
owe 13 was Android studio to help make
the Android tools the best tools the
tools team have created an Android
developer tools community on Google+
join us to talk tools with the tools
team of course it wouldn't be google i/o
without the i/o app in the android
design in action team have performed a
full teardown showing how was put
together on last week's show they also
dive into building sharing into your app
and creating immersive full screen you
wires for all the chet haase fans out
there we've got more chat bytes last
week's episode explored animating
ListView deletion chat will be joining
us in the hot seat later this week for
the first episode of devbytes backstage
he'll be joining us to answer all your
animation questions so send them in or
join us live on Thursday via our hangout
not to be outdone Nick and Roman will be
answering your design questions this
Friday last week the app clinic team had
the pleasure of joining the Oslo Google
developers group for our second GDG app
clinic Oslo is beautiful this time of
year also they told us when we connected
over hangouts keep an eye out for the
video this Wednesday also last week we
try to hand at teaching people Android
in person hosting our annual Android
camp for 30 of the brightest sophomores
and juniors from some of the top
universities in the country will be
taking the show over the pond in August
to teach Android to some of the
brightest students not in this country
will also be making these instructor-led
training materials available for
download so the same quality Android
education will soon be available to
everyone including mediocre students at
below-average universities in the
meantime we're publishing plenty of
great learning material on
developer.android.com such as the last
week's release of the purchase status
API guide it was a big week in app
releases too with BBC weather launching
and quickly
rocketing to the top of the Google Play
UK charts it's a beautiful pure Android
app so it's no surprise to see it do
well it is currently available only to
users in the UK but the team is hard at
work adding support for forecasts that
aren't cloudy with a chance of rain
developers using Google Play game
services have also been hard at work
with jewel to becoming the first cross
platform game to use these new services
that means you can compare your jewel
matching skills with friends using all
manner of internet-connected rounded
corner rectangular devices one tap hero
also want an upgrade this week that saw
it integrate leaderboards while what's
this launch support for Google+ sign-in
leaderboards and achievements coming up
in Android developers live this week
we've got a new biz dev bite from shazia
who's introducing Google Play for
education and explaining how you can get
involved this week's app clinic will
feature GDG Vilnius from Lithuania
there's nearly twice as many mobile
phones in Lithuania as there are people
so it's no surprise to see these guys
are passionate about android development
you can track all of the upcoming
android developers live shows at
developers.google.com / live / android
that's all for this week in Android
development for jun 17 2013 join us for
this week's Android developers live
broadcast and remember we're up all
night for good fun we're up all night to
code Android